everybody it's so nice to see you back
at today's rstudio community meetup
if we haven't had a chance to meet yet
and this is your first meetup i'm rachel
calling in from boston today
it's so nice to meet you
feel free to introduce yourselves
through the chat window and say hello as
well i love getting to see where people
are calling in from all over the world
and
to also see people sharing helpful
resources with each other there in the
chat too
i host these meetups every tuesday at
noon eastern time and they are all
recorded and shared up to the r studio
youtube if you ever want to go back and
check out past sessions too
it will be the same exact link that you
joined
the meetup from today that same youtube
link
if this is your first meetup this is a
friendly meetup environment for teens to
share different use cases with each
other and teach lessons learned
together we're all dedicated to making
this an inclusive and open environment
for everyone no matter your experience
industry or background
you can add the whole calendar of events
or individual events to your own
calendar
with a link that i'll show on
the screen here in just a few minutes oh
here we go i'll show it now
you can use this link to find out about
any upcoming events
for a heads up about next week we will
have julia silgi and isabel zimmerman
with us here
next tuesday to talk about ml ops with
with vetiver in python and r
today i am
so excited to have you all here for our
sports analytics meetup with the nfl big
data bull
2022 winners led by robin brendan riker
and elijah all here with me today i've
seen a lot on twitter and linkedin about
their team and i'm excited for us all to
be able to ask them questions here today
as well
so during the event you can ask
questions on youtube
live where you're watching from
and are also able to ask anonymous
questions as well
through
rstd dot io slash meetup questions which
i'll put on the screen here too
with that i would love to pull everybody
up on stage let me do this one by one
here
here we go
and robin brendan riker elijah thank you
so much for for joining here today
rob and brendan reicher and elijah are
all graduate students in statistics at
simon fraser university in
vancouver canada
they each have a passion for sports
analytics and enjoy applying their stats
knowledge to the game
first off i want to congrat say
congratulations and thank you so much
for being here to share your experience
with us today
i will pull the slides up here as well
and turn it over to you all
all right hi everyone and welcome to our
presentation we're extremely excited to
be able to share our work with you all
today
so today we'll be presenting on our 2022
nfl big data bowl grand champion winning
project we'll provide details on the
math behind the path and introduce some
upgrades we've made since the conclusion
of the competition
so sfu has been a sports analytics
powerhouse for years professors such as
tim schwartz and luke bourne have
attracted students who have a passion
for statistics and sports
together they have revolutionized the
department and have helped students land
jobs with professional teams such as the
seattle kraken la rams sacramento kings
vancouver canucks and many many more
sfu's big data bowl success started in
2019 where a team of students won the
college competition and were again
finalists in 2021
their work really inspired us to
continue on the sap tradition and their
mentorship helped us throughout the
entire process
so before we get into the project let's
meet the team
so my name is riker i am a current
masters of statistics student at sfu i
formally interned with the vancouver
canucks of the nhl and am currently an
intern with the detroit lions of the nfl
hi everyone
my name is robin i'm a phd candidate
at simon fraser university and i'm
focusing on revolutionizing the game of
curling with analytics and machine
learning tools
in addition to the big data bowl i was
part of the winning team of the big data
cup this year
so for that we use tracking data to
evaluate passing in women's olympic
hockey
hi everyone my name is brandon i'm
currently a master's student at simon
frasier university and a data analyst
intern at exolus analytics and i also
won the big data cup just a year before
robin then the 2021 competition where i
worked with a few others in building out
a
expected possession value model for
hockey so evaluating every single
um event set of play
and hi my name's elijah i'm also a
masters of statistics student at sfu and
i'm currently an intern with the
pittsburgh pirates
all right for those of you who are
unfamiliar here's a quick overview of
last year's big data bowl competition
so this was the competition's fourth
year and the subject was chosen to be on
special teams
special teams includes plays like punt
returns kick returns field goals and
extra points
we are provided data from three nfl
seasons including next gen stats
tracking data pff advanced scouting data
and other basic stats from the nfl
in total there were a hundred thousand
dollars in prizes awarded to three
college and five open finals
and then we were lucky enough to be
named the grand champions out of these
eight finalists
so now for a bit of inspiration behind
the project
this is an entry into this year's 2022
big data bowl by zach rogers and this
gives good motivation for our work it
puts you in the shoes of the punt
returner
if you can imagine that you are the punt
returner what should you look for after
receiving the pun
our project aimed to answer a couple of
these main questions so firstly are
returners making good decisions to
increase yards are they finding optimal
gaps assessing tackle risk and are they
using their teammates and following
their blocks
secondly we wanted to determine who was
the best at evaluating their decision
could we rank returners which could then
allow coaches to determine the best
returners based on a given situation
now i'll toss it over to robin and
brendan and we'll go over some more
details of the project
cool thank you so
now that we
know what the punt returner needs to
consider
and what our goals are we want to be
able to find show the best path to the
end zone like we see in green on the
figure here
the observed path is shown in black the
returner and his team are shown in
yellow and gray while the kick team
players are shown in pink
so the first step in building our
optimal path is to find gaps in the kick
team's coverage for this we use delani
triangulation so this is a mesh-like
structure that connects the points such
that all players in the hull
are all connected
to form triangles with no lines
overlapping
this is shown with the purple lines
between any two kick team players
and to account for the punt returner
going around all the players and towards
sidelines we add new gaps that connect
the players on the outside of the hull
to the boundaries of the zone of
interest
these are shown by the vertical and
horizontal purple lines here
some of the interesting packages we use
are tri-mesh and neighbors from the
tripac family
and now that we have the software um
sorry these windows to find that the
part returner can move through on his
way towards the end zone we want to move
towards quantifying the pressure along
each of these windows and we do this
using our penal as expected arrival time
algorithm to give a bit of visual
intuition behind this algorithm if you
look at that heat line in the top left
of the plot here
you could see that towards the sideline
it's color green indicating that there's
a lot of open space there and it's going
to take the members of the kicking team
a long time to get to that position
well as you move closer and closer to
where all the players are you can see
that it goes from green to yellow to red
indicating that there's more pressure
and less time for the pump returner to
move through that area
and to kind of formalize this a little
bit more the goal of this algorithm is
to obtain the minimum time we expect it
to take a member of the kicking team in
red here to reach the target location as
indicated by the exterior and we're
going to take a bunch of different
target locations but let's just focus on
this single spot right here
so with that target location we're going
to look at every kicking team player on
the field or every player in red that's
trying to stop the punt returner from
moving forward and what's
say we just look at number 97 for
example to start off here um so with
number 97 what we're going to do is
we're going to create a straight line
connecting him to that target location
and once we do that we're going to find
all blockers that we can project onto
this straight line at a 90 degree angle
and that's going to sort of be all of
the blockers that can really reasonably
impede his path from getting to that
target location
so here we have number 82 and number 19.
and for these blockers we're going to
take two different measurements
so first we're going to take the length
of that projection from 82 to the
straight line as indicated by d1 here
and that's going to be a measure of the
lateral distance from the kicking team
player
and then we're going to take the
distance from number 97 to that
projection and that's going to be
indicated by d2 here and that's sort of
the forward distance from the kick and
team flare to the blocker
and with these two measurements we're
going to attribute time penalties for
each of the blockers using what we call
a projected gaussian kernel and that's
characterized by the equation right here
and the heat map below
and sort of what we're trying to do here
is to create an equation where um we're
kind of accurately capturing how much a
blocker is likely to impede a member of
the kicking team's path to that target
location
right so you can see here that when
you're very close and right in front of
number 97 you're going to impose a very
high penalty whereas as you move further
and further out you can be a bit more
lateral from the
picking team player or from number 97
but you you have less of a penalty
overall right because if you're say
you're
right in front of number 97 like one
foot forward from him but
five feet to the left then you're less
likely to actually
cap or catch him or impede him than if
you're
say ten feet forward from and five feet
to the left
and once we assign these blocker
penalties we're going to simply add them
all up
so with number 19 and number 82 they
impose the 0.54 and 0.31 second penalty
on number 97 respectively giving us a
total penalty of 0.85 seconds by these
two blockers
and then we're going to calculate the
expected time to the target location for
number 97 given that he runs at a
straight line speed of 7 yards per
second and that's going to be 2.34
seconds then we add these two values up
so the time that we expect him to take
to get to that target location going to
heat it as 2.34 and the blocker penalty
that we expect to happen as 0.85 and
that's going to give us 3.19 seconds for
number 97 to that target
and we're going to repeat this process
over and over for every member of the
kicking team and on the left here you
can see we have a little table with the
top few players here and number 17 is
the quickest to get to that target
location at 0.92 seconds in this in this
case
um and that's sort of that's going to be
our measure of the time we expect a
member of the kicking team to get to
that location or our penalized expected
arrival time
and we're going to repeat this process
over and over for up to 20 evenly spaced
points along each of these windows so on
the so that's where we get that sort of
line map on the left here where you can
see or where we're basically just taking
a bunch of different targets and we're
smoothing them out to get a nice um
these nice kind of color transitions
over each of the windows
and now i'll pass it back over to robin
to talk about
how we go from this funeral as expected
arrival time measure to actually finding
the optimal path through the venues
great so now that we have our mesh
structure and a waiting system for it we
need to find a way to get the punt
returner to the end zone and to do this
we use the a star search algorithm
so it works a little bit like a gps and
just finds the safest route while
avoiding traffic our algorithm looks at
a heuristic function which defines how
many yards are remaining from the target
to the end zone and a cost function
this cost function describes the
distance between the pump returner and
the target
the danger associated with the target
point as well as how risky of a target
the punt returner may be
willing to consider traveling to
the algorithm looks at various possible
routes and restarts whenever the total
of the heuristic and cost function
become too large
we can
set a few constants to help us
with the trade-off between risk and
reward for the punt returner so today
we're going to really focus on the alpha
term and see how changing it might
adjust this trade-off between risk and
reward
so for our submission if you have if you
had the chance to look at it we used
alpha of 0.5
so we considered this to be a good
mixture of risk and reward for a punt
returner wanting to gain yards while
still
avoiding the tackle avoiding injury
stuff like that if we were to change
alpha to b1
the path considers only yards remaining
to the end zone with no care of the
danger of being tackled so this would
mean that you're going basically
straight to the end zone and hopefully
that you can push everyone out of the
way
and then setting alpha to zero finds the
safest path available without
considering if it's really going to
bring you
closer to the end zone so this typically
will send you along the sidelines and
push you the rest of the way
and now that we have this optimal path
defined let's just take a look at a case
here where we set alpha equal to 0.5
and we want to compare the optimal path
versus our or the actual observed path
for the part returner and to do that we
look over the next five yards for each
of the path so as you can see on the top
right here in the visual we have sort of
the highlighted uh black and green line
over the next five yards and we want to
calculate the for shade distance over
this this time
and purchase distance is a measure of
difference between two paths where
essentially intuitively you can think of
it as one path being a man the other
path being a dog and the perche distance
is the minimum length of a leash you
need to traverse from
one end of the path to the other end
and you can see visually a bit of visual
intuition behind this uh with the blue
lines here you can see that's sort of
like steps along each of these paths
and the teal line there is another step
but it's just the step where the length
is maximized and that's sort of the
minimum length of the leash that you
would need contributes from both ends
and with this for shade distance we also
have to take into account a couple of
other things
just in case there are cases where
there's less than five yards remaining
in either the observed or the optimal
path
so if there aren't so if both paths are
more than five yards then we just simply
calculate the crochet distance and
that's sort of our measure of deviation
from the optimal path in that moment
but if either of the paths are between
one and five yards then we're going to
multiply the frechet distance by five
and divide it by the minimum of those
two the minimum length of those two
paths to sort of scale up and account
for the fact that on that path we aren't
really seeing a full five yard movement
so we're trying to um kind of counteract
that
and if there's less than one yard on
either of the paths then we omit the
calculations since we don't really have
enough information to see
how the point return it was moving
relative to the optimal path
and
yeah with with this optimal path
algorithm we also just wanted to give a
quick shout out to some of the key r
functions that really helped us in this
process um so first up nest and map were
super helpful for
making this whole process very tidy and
clean and
and being able to apply large scale
analysis
using very complex operations within
just a single data frame so nest
essentially allows you to
group say you want to group the data by
moment or by each frame of the play
where a frame is simply just a moment in
time
but you add 20 rows of player locations
if you group by the player by the frame
then you can sort of nest the data into
a column of data frames which includes
all of the player locations so you have
one row per frame but within that row
you have sort of a data frame of all of
the player locations
then with the map function you can start
applying different functions to that
data
so you can apply
basically functions to
find the windows for the partnership to
move through or calculate the penalize
expected arrival time or
find the
optimal path with the a-star algorithm
using this map function all within one
data frame and future map is just an
evolution beyond that where you can
parallelize the code so it runs a bit
quicker
and deep wire of course was super
helpful for us just with building out
sort of a tiny burst pipeline with key
functions like mutate uh select and
filter
and also the pipe operator making the
code nice and sleek
um then of course our our all of our
plots here are made with g plot and gg
animate and it's
those packages are just super awesome
for making very nice aesthetically
pleasing plots with very little effort
okay
pause for a second
for questions if there are any
kind of the key content of
what our submission
optimal path was
yeah you can see a question that came
over from slido and just to remem a
reminder that you can ask questions over
on slido and i'll just put up the
link right now on the screen
so you can ask questions there
anonymously or you can ask through
youtube live too
but one of the questions that came up
was
i'll put on the screen do you think
being in a general statistics graduate
program was beneficial to your work as
opposed to more specific like data
science or sports analytics
that's a good question there might be
debates there um
i think like so we'll talk a little bit
later um
but for our work a key aspect
in in building a team um is definitely
to have a good variety of backgrounds so
having someone who is like a statistics
graduate to really understand like the
models and what's going on behind it is
great if you could get like a computer
scientist on there
they're super efficient and can write
code probably a lot faster than a lot of
us
stats hulk
yeah but it's definitely good to have
always someone on your team with a stats
background to understand what's going on
but a mixture of various backgrounds and
and
departments and origin stories is always
always great to see
that's great thank you
one other question i see over on slido
i'll put on the screen here is
um
did you calculate
p or p-e-a-t at just a single point in
time at catch or at multiple points
during the return
yeah that's a great question so yeah we
we calculated the p basically at every
single frame of the play
um and then for our big data ball
submission we were sort of taking the
median over the entire play just because
there are a few frames where say a punt
returner is running
in a path that's
maybe not the optimal path buyer
algorithm but also a very good option
then after a few frames the optimal path
should adjust to that but during that
time when they are running and the
optimal pass telling them to go a
different way
it is it has
quite a big crochet deviation so the
median or we took the media to sort of
account for that and adjust for the fact
sort of for our naivety or not there
could be two different very great great
options um so that's what we were doing
for the big data bowl but we've also
played around with metrics we're looking
at it just right at catch
um taking the mean looking at say the
frame where there's the first forward
movement
and just different metrics like that but
yeah basically you can calculate it over
every frame and we'll maybe cut in and
add a little bit the questions about
pete and you're asking answering for
shea deviation
is just like calculated all the time all
over the place
can you remind me what he is yeah
yeah so the p is basically like um i'll
go back to that heat map that we had or
the little heat lines here so this is
the penalized expected rival time um
along each of the windows here sorry
it's a little bit early in the morning
in pacific right now
but yeah here's some along each of the
windows this is the peat here so it's
sort of like the measure of how long it
will take the apartment to occur how
long it will take the kicking team to
get to that location
like any of these locations whereas the
fresher deviation is sort of um
it's how much the pipe retainer is
deviating from
the optimal path
so yeah we calculate everything in every
single frame
thank you
um i see a few other just comments to
say extremely impressive word but we'll
hold some of the other questions until
the next stopping point if that works
for you
for sure
okay
so all right let me fix let me fix our
screen here
okay
there we go
um
okay so to make our work a little bit
more interactive we built a shiny app so
that everyone here today can have a look
at our optimal path
not any return that you might want to
see throughout all the years the data
that we have
so as the user
you can select the season the returner
the play and set the risk alpha that you
want the punt returner to consider when
making
his optimal path i guess um so you can
look at the return at any point along
the way by hitting the play button in
the top right corner
or you can use the slider bar to look at
any specific point along the return
so you're given
a description of what the return
looks like
or what the return actually achieved uh
and then you have the option to save it
as the image of the individual frame
that you're looking at you can save the
gif of the entire return or the data
that's behind the return if you want to
look at it and play with it yourself
uh so
maybe we'll look at the nicole hardman
or we can go live so let's let's go live
and have a bit of sorry
that's fine um
cool so brendan will reload our app
um so maybe don't try to log on right
away because we want to make sure we're
efficient for you guys uh so we can
start off by picking a year let's pick
2020 maybe
um and then if anyone in the comments do
you have like a favorite putt returner
that you might want to see from the 2020
season
feel free to comment now
give it a second
on i know somebody wants to put someone
in there
you can do it anonymously too
don't see anyone all right eli do you
have a favorite
i hear uh general ol chesky is good if i
did butcher's name
sure we can go for garner
oh here's one
uh
uh mckenzie you want to switch to him
okay is there a specific game that you
like for
for this returner so there's oh there's
only one
we can go with that okay
um brenden you want to read their
description
yeah for sure yeah so in on this part
return um
it looks like half took a 55 year
apartment turned to or he made a 55-yard
punt
uh to isaiah mckenzie who ran 84 yards
for a touchdown so i guess you're right
so wait wait wait wait don't donate okay
so
now like
consider that type of a play you have a
big pun return what quarter are we in
we're kind of small here i can make it
bigger
so we're in the
second quarter
five
it's almost six minutes in so where do
we think we should put our alpha should
we be
considered risky or i guess if you went
84 yards it's probably something a
little risky
so what do we like maybe point seven we
can
i'd say
point seven or point eight let's do
point seven or point eight okay
so we can generate it and then
it takes a little bit of time because
there's a whole lot of math going on as
you as you saw us go through before
um
so it's working on the a starter search
algorithm there's a loading bar so you
know that you at least hit the button
and you don't have to click it a bunch
of times
um and then we'll see the entire
uh
image of the return come up
and then in the top right it'll have the
slider bar so it'll update and tell you
how long of the
the return actually lasted you can play
through it where it'll just kind of do
like a little slideshow of
of each frame of the play
hopefully being
screen sharing isn't stealing all of
brendan's
computer juice
yeah i guess yeah it's a longer return
so it's going to take a while to
to generate longer ones
the shorter ones are pretty fast
is there any other questions rachel to
fill our our next five seconds
one question that i had was
like thinking about people getting
started if with the big data bowl for
2023 and you just have all this data
how do you narrow down
what you want to focus on
yeah so
typically um so we're not sure what
they're going to announce this year for
the big data bowl but i think they're
leaning towards
having a top a general topic each year
so for us it was punt returns so this
year who knows what it might be
um
but yeah just like
definitely you start by just like
looking at the data seeing what you can
find
um and playing around make some
histograms make some
pie charts anything you can do just to
understand the data it's going to be a
lot of data and i'm really hard to run
so often just like
looking at a couple
plays or one good play make sure
everything works for that play before
you scale it up too big because some of
our stuff it would run i think riker was
running stuff like overnight and then if
we had to like
find one error you'd you'd fix it and
then you'd go and run everything again
overnight so it's
you don't want to start there you want
to start small maybe which is one good
play and see what you can do
yeah and definitely definitely you know
we had kind of a broad topic with
special teams there's a lot of different
ways we could go with it
but figuring out what what's going to be
useful as well in in a football sense
and then like robin said kind of getting
a general idea how the data looks what's
going to be possible
and then kind of running with it from
there
yeah
we definitely had a lot of other ideas
like are we gonna do you know field
goals we're gonna do this and that and
then it's just kind of
trial and error and getting closer to
what you think is the best idea
yeah okay so our return is loaded
brendan maybe you want to
play around with round with it and
yeah so you can grab the slider bar look
look at the whole frame or hit play and
hopefully it loads somewhat smoothly it
tends to blink a little bit
um so right now it's just at like point
i think it updates at 0.1
seconds so it'll take a little while to
get through this gigantic return
but you can see the optimal path will
update at every single frame all the
calculations are redone every frame so
it's a lot of data that you're really
seeing right now
um working with track data is definitely
great experience like even if you're not
ready to enter the big data bowl maybe
you don't have
your star lineup ready
play around with the data like get used
to working with tracking data is
definitely something if you want to
start a career in in sports analytics
just
getting those tools in in your toolkit
is is definitely super useful
and then once the pot returner passes
the final kick team player all
calculations kind of stop and we're just
like
we just put a straight arrow as like
book it to the end zone
but obviously he still kind of has to
run away and avoid anyone who's super
fast
it might be frozen now
well that's awkward there was
other questions that came through when
we asked uh earlier too and
and someone had asked
could you see potential for this being
used real time somewhere down the line
with increased processing power
um so one article i did see
um
come out in the summer i think it was it
was like the ultimate big data bull
recap and for our year it talked about
creating the
the ultimate submission would be like a
combination of zack rogers like
put you in the punt returner like video
game and then you could see our optimal
path like
projected through all the players that
you might be running towards so that you
could actually learn from it in a video
game sense would be like
amazing
um so maybe if they could get it to that
level and make like a video game for
punt returners to learn as they're off
the field
would would be
a wild for me
so one day maybe
that's awesome i just
definitely sorry about it
sorry to cut you off rachel i was gonna
say as well like kind of a uh a
post-game or a post-game analysis of how
you did as a returner um so if the
processing power is unfortunately not
there uh for an in-game thing i think
like a post-game analysis of
of kind of of your performance or
performances for pun returners across
the league is i would be a great use for
this
that's great um one last question too
that i saw come in a little a little bit
earlier is someone asked is it possible
to share code for future reference
um for us all of our code is on github
awesome we can share that link at the
that it's on their end slide so we can
you can look at that thereafter
cool thank you
yeah um so richard you can share the
shiny app link in the chat if you want
for everyone to
play around with um
so a little bit more we'll go into this
nicole hardman return on the next slide
um so here we're going to show nicole
hardman's week 12 return against tampa
bay
where we have an alpha of zero so
be as safe as possible 0.5 kind of a
good mix of risk and reward and one
which basically just says run straight
to the end zone plow through everyone if
you need to
so in our big data bowl finals
presentation uh we concluded that nicole
hardman was a fairly conservative player
and we can use our app to further
analyze just how conservative he is
so if you want to play
the gifts so the optimal path updates at
each frame constantly updating and
adapting to the situation that michael
hardman is facing
suggesting a new optimal path given each
situation and overall nicole hardman
we think could use this tool to improve
his return because a lot of his return
is
probably closest to a risk level of zero
which
you know we kind of want to gain yards
as as we do a return
but it depends on the scenario right
he's a valuable player in his other
other role on the team so it's
you kind of want to keep him safe at the
same time so things like that could
influence how you might determine what
alpha you might want to use
eli
yeah okay so i'm going to take over now
and talk about um
kind of what we ended up doing after the
initial submission let's go to the next
slide
yeah so the
um the task that the nfl gave us was to
look at a look at a specific team and
try to find out how we could use the
work we did to improve you know their
results in the coming seasons so we
picked kansas city so as you can see
like in 2018 they are really highly
ranked in terms of you know average punt
return yardage and that kind of fell off
in 2019 and 2020 which coincided with
tyreek hill um the returner being
changed to cole harmon who
robert just showed and so after watching
some of nicole harmon's puns we kind of
we kind of chose the chiefs as someone
that we thought we could improve
and we can see why in this plot so
if you look at the nicole harmon plot on
the far right he often kind of just goes
towards the sidelines he's not cutting
up and you know running
up the middle of the field where there's
obviously going to be more defenders we
also have more blockers and there might
be more space to maneuver and we can
kind of contrast him with the other
three pump returners on the right who
rank really highly in our expected uh
return yardage metric or or just on
average punt return yardage they're
they're much stronger returners you can
see that by the really long
uh returns for some of them
and so the way we quantify that is by
looking at you know their average yards
gained per pump return versus their for
for shay path deviation so the crochet
deviation is kind of um a concept of
good decision making so being close to
the optimal path versus you know average
yards gain will play is more of a just
skill metric of you know it's dependent
on how fast you are and obviously the
strength of your blockers
and the strength of the uh of the kitten
team so we can look at nicole hartman
he's kind of on the bottom right of that
plot which means he doesn't have a lot
of skill and he's not making uh great
decisions um and that's you know
contrasting to the other three
highlighted names who were the same who
were the um returners we saw on the last
slide who who are very strong returners
and so the idea is you know if you
decrease your shape path deviation you
know that might lead you to gaining more
yards on the average return
and so here are examples of uh of two
different plays um where we see
you know when the in the
plot on the left with the green plot
when harmon follows the optimal path or
gets closer to it he gets
closer to what we might expect
him to get in terms of expected yards
versus on the right and on the plot on
the red he doesn't
you know get really close to what we
might have uh we might expect using our
expected punt return yardage metric uh
and that's because you know he's his
shape path deviation is very very large
i'll say maybe we should skip this
questions for the end and just
power through for time
all right and then just talking about
more generally you know how to
um
have a good submission for the big data
bowl i think one of the biggest parts is
like robin mentioned earlier information
having a very diverse team with you know
many different skill sets you know i i
come from more of like a math physics
background very different from the
background that maybe robin has you know
doing an underground stats and so that
helped us we kind of brought different
ideas to the table
and then you know brainstorming
you know as rob announced mentioned
earlier making visualization so you know
exploratory data analysis seeing what
kind of data you have
what kind of
paths might you go through
in terms of different projects
you know just running with something and
then not being afraid of scrapping it
and going in a different direction if
you see a better direction
you know as you're working
doing research looking at
different sports is something that i
think is
one of the biggest things we
and the next slide will show
one of the concepts that we were kind of
taking from a different sports soccer so
using other sports using other
researchers there could be a great tool
towards building a really nice project
and looking at previous big data
projects as obviously you know there's
some great work there as well
and then you know trial and error and
just being willing to adapt and uh
change your project and um yeah work
hard and have fun
yeah so here is kind of what i mentioned
so originally the kind of first idea we
started with with these like sarcastic
convex hulls which we kind of took as an
idea from soccer so we're kind of
looking at um
you know
uh an area enclosed in a certain amount
of
yards by the defenders and the
uh and the return team to kind of get an
understanding for like kind of um
uh field control like what the picking
team and the pun and the
returning team might have in terms of a
field control and how that might we
could use as a feature to might to to
like you know create like an expected
yards metric
and then you know
we developed that idea we moved forward
we started you know developing the a
star search algorithm started developing
the p-e-a-t so that all kind of came out
from this initial idea of the convex
hulls
all right so for any of you who are
interested in the 2023 or beyond those
big data bulls this is what we kind of
believe makes a good submission
so firstly we think do a few things
great rather than several things good
the goal is really to stand out to the
judges and we think this is kind of how
you do that
second have multiple ways to digest
ideas so this could be through
visuals text equations
titles uh or even captions
the third is to be really clear and
concise with your project so
have a goal in mind what problem are you
trying to solve
then determine the method how are you
going to solve this problem
and then apply it it's really important
for your project to be useful to the nfl
and for you to explain how it could be
useful
lastly have fun and learn as much as you
can
not only from your own project but many
all of the many great submissions uh
every year
all right so that's really everything we
have for you guys today um on the left
there we have qr codes that take you to
our original submission um the github
page like we mentioned earlier as well
as the shiny app that we uh we showed
you guys
we really appreciate the opportunity to
talk to you about our work
and really want to thank everyone for
coming out today and obviously thank you
rachel for having us um we'd be happy to
answer any more questions that you guys
may have
thank you all so much this is awesome
really impressive
especially just like being able to see
it through all the animations too and
the presentation was great
i'm gonna go check over to slido and
see what questions we have but just want
to remind everybody if you're watching
now on youtube you don't have to use
slido you can just comment in
youtube
but you can ask questions anonymously on
slido too
let me just pull that up
on the screen right here
and we'll give people a few minutes to
ask some other questions
i see christopher and brian saying
amazing work fantastic stuff
in the chats on the
on youtube
i really like the way that you
included like tips for people who are
wanting to get started
and was just thinking like
on the last tip that you said focus on
like a few
like great things instead of like trying
to do everything
were there a few things that you had to
narrow down
to get to where you got
to the project now
yeah i think we i think we had like kind
of eli went over when we you know we
kind of built it up from the ground up
and had these like convex hulls and then
developed it more into like the optimal
path
um and then once we got the idea for the
optimal path and uh brendan and robin
kind of took the lead on that side that
became a real focal point for us so we
did have a lot of those other
like original ideas we used those as
features in our return of expected model
but they weren't as featured in the
project we really tried to hone in on
the optimal path and make that the the
focal point
and definitely while you're working on
your submission i think for us it was
you're allowed up to 2 000 words
which doesn't go a long way
so like definitely
having visuals that kind of explain
what's going on too can save you a lot
of time and space
so you don't like if you do too many
small things you won't be able to
explain it um near the extent it would
deserve
so it's nice to be able to do this where
it's like we can actually
show people all the hidden elements that
they didn't get to see and
and would never really know if we didn't
go through this
i just remembered i wanted to show this
um
link to the kaggle
uh documentation you had shared with me
too i just made a short link to make it
easier for people to to access it
but one other question that just came
through on slido was
what were the biggest challenges when
going through the data
um first of all the the size of it
um how how much was there um really
trying to
really trying to utilize like every
piece that they provided for us like
trying to really diversify
how we were building out the project
but like i got mentioned a few times
throughout the presentation the the
amount of the amount of tracking data is
really the challenging
really the challenging part and then
being able to turn that into
our own
um our own metrics was was also a
challenge
yeah i can't remember it was the nfl or
somewhere else but i think they're they
have the ability to go like
another
10 times of a finer grain of tracking
data but they're just like please don't
we do not have the the capacity to like
to be able to even use that like it's
too fine so there are like
hopefully they don't go too crazy but
it's a it's an interesting
area to work with is
the tracking data
yeah and with that too i'd just like to
say the nfl tracking it was probably the
nicest data i'd work with and how clean
it was and just easy to work with like
there weren't really
any errors there might have been like
one time i might have saw a player where
two players had the same number
jersey number but that's that's about it
like it was pretty smooth
there were no discontinuities in uh the
tracking data at all really so it just
made it so much easier to work with yeah
like riker was mentioning size was the
biggest issue just with dealing with all
of this these millions of rows of data
but actually
having to clean up the data was super
easy
yeah you know i definitely having
like a team to work with can alleviate a
lot of the challenges because we like
the way our project was we approached
our project was we split it up and if
you have a strong computer you're doing
the data cleaning and if if you have a
weak computer you're going to do the
research and we kind of like split up
the different tasks that we had to face
that we could always have
everyone doing something and progressing
the project
that's great
um
elijah i think you were going to say
something i want to jump to the next
question
no
i was going to actually just mention to
brendan like and robin they've both done
more like
uh projects with hockey tracking data
and you know you have players kind of
coming into the frame then at leaving
the frame and they kind of just appear
and disappear sometimes out of magic
versus yeah like with the nfl uh big
datable data like that you know the data
is really really clean
you know we've really made it when you
have people spamming your um
meet up as well so
um
but let's let's see what other um
weather questions oh one question i did
want to ask is um
how do you get started working with
player tracking data were there
resources that you turn to
i think a lot of us had a bit of
experience uh prior to um whether it be
in school or
um through internships or other just
other projects i know like
uh was mentioned you know brendan had
worked with big the big data cup the
year before um
[Music]
yeah like i'm i i'm sure these guys have
have some resources but um for for me it
was just kind of like
diving right into it and figuring it out
as you go
yeah i think for me i'd only worked with
event level data before going into this
competition
um and just like the key thing that i
really focused on and needed was like i
need the visual
i like i won't understand that it's
working you can give me something
a bunch of numbers but like if i can
have a visual to go
with it that like definitely
helps with the understanding of what's
going on like a million times
yeah yeah i'd say yeah like along those
lines um
having good knowledge of tidy bursts and
using those nests and map functions and
gpu animate made it so much easier to
understand the data because
if you can kind of put it into this nice
clean pipeline where you can break it
down into like one row per frame or per
player or whatever you need
then you can just visualize it with gg
animate it makes it so much easier to
see what's actually going on
rather than just looking at the data and
seeing like x coordinate
34y coordinate 43 or something so
that just made it way way easier to
kind of
get going and see where issues
were happening if they were happening
cool so get started with
gg animate
that's that would be yeah
let me just jump over there's a few
other questions on slido
let me copy them over to the screen here
this one is in terms of
all your data inputs do you see this
extending to performance data like
expected speed fatigue etc perhaps from
practice
yeah yeah i think um
one thing that
we
talked about quite a bit is sort of like
a lot of comments that we got were
around just with um
our optimal path algorithm really what
we're trying to optimize is just gaining
yards but there's a lot else going on in
the play like a player could get hit and
fumble the ball get injured so there's
like i guess that's one thing that our
algorithm doesn't really take into
account um
in terms of
like expected speed we're also working
on right now incorporating players
themes into our optimal path algorithm
too
so with that like you can maybe look at
say nicole hartman a lot of the times he
was running to the sideline but he is
pretty fast so incorporating that into
the data might
might make the optimal path shift a bit
more towards what he was doing um in
certain cases so
that's one thing where i think the model
can be improved and i think yeah we're
pretty close to having that now we're
actually hoping to present that in about
a week and a half from now at a another
conference um but yeah like that's
that's something that we were kind of
looking at in a comment that we got
quite a bit
awesome thank you
i'm curious do you all normally win your
like fantasy football leagues
uh we're all in one together together
that just finished its first week and it
was a bit rough for some of us
[Laughter]
one other
new model
yeah
for the answer yes we usually win
okay one of the other question was at
any point during the project did you
feel like you hit uh roadblock
yeah well i mean like with our projects
really for
when we started in september we didn't
really work on it super super hard until
december when our courses ended
um
like because we had a couple of like
very difficult courses to go through
that were sucking up a lot of our time
uh so once we got through that
uh there were a couple days where i was
thinking like man are we gonna get it
done in time um and
there were a few things like trying to
find out say the penal as expected
arrival time algorithm trying to find
ways to actually
do that it took a little while to really
think through it and come up with an
algorithm to actually do that um
yeah that i guess that's the one
roadblock that came to mind that into
school kind of getting in the way but
yeah yeah i think i don't know if you
guys have anything to add there
yeah i remember uh i think it was i
think it was due on like the 7th of
january or something and i remember
january 4th we realized that we had
calculated something completely wrong
so the overnight running the code
overnight that robin talked about he had
to redo
three days before it was uh before it
was due
um
so that was a little bit stressful um
but
uh happy we happy we turned it around
and made it work
that's great
so i know you've mentioned like forming
your team with like diverse backgrounds
is really important
i'm wondering for people who maybe
are working in
like
different industries right now but are
also super interested in sports and big
data bowl
if you have any suggestions for like
meeting people that could possibly be
part of their team
um i'll maybe yeah so
for the big data bulletin we typically
stay sfu um but like stuff for the big
data cup um
like
maybe brendan you can talk about how you
formed your big data cup team because
that's different
yeah yeah so yeah like robin was
mentioning for this one i just emailed
all the students who were interested in
sports and we formed a team but for the
big data cup i just met my teammates
online like on twitter so i think
twitter's a great resource for sports
analytics because there's
so many people on there just sharing
their ideas through blogs or through
videos and just various forms of media
um so i think that's a great way to kind
of get involved and like interact with
other people who are in the industry and
trying to get into the industry
um and yeah i literally just uh met one
of my teammates online through twitter
and then we said how are we going to get
other people then
we emailed one guy that he knew and then
that was three then we thought oh man we
need maybe someone with a bit more of
like a strong statistical background
because at the time i was just finishing
my undergrad and the other two guys were
more of like hockey oriented guys
so then we just reached out to a guy who
went to the same university as
my other teammate and he happened to be
in he was a phd at mcgill uh and then
now he's i'm working with him directly
in my internship
so uh yeah that's that's sort of like
like he was a big help to that and
without him we probably wouldn't have
gotten that done so
yeah like it just ended up just
snowballing from just being on twitter
and meeting one guy and then meeting
other people from that and not turning
into the big data cup then internships
from there
yeah definitely if you want to get
started um i'd recommend like getting on
twitter and
play around with any kind of data that
you can get your hands on
and just share it like the community is
huge for sports analytics on twitter and
we'll shout out sports dataverse which i
know you've had on here before like
follow them on twitter
there's so many people in that community
who who would help lift each other up
and and support any project or questions
that you might have
that's great i know um
sam from sports dataverse was on a bit
earlier he might be on now too if you
want to share the
link and um
to twitter as well
i know you also mentioned like a
a great idea to look at other sports to
get ideas and to do brainstorming
um
what did you look at or what other
sports data were you working with
probably the most publicly available
with some tracking data so like tracking
data is very
hidden and not a lot of people share it
so it's like amazing that the nfl is
doing this
um so all the other big data bulls will
have some tracking data a lot of them
and then soccer is a huge one that has
tracking data and like
properly published papers using it
explaining all the stuff that works i
think soccer is one of the biggest ones
to to look at
and then the big data cup recently this
year started using tracking data so all
those papers and that data is publicly
available
supported by stathletes who made the
data from broadcast video
um so just get your hands on stuff and
do what you can
great thank you i think there's one more
question that i realized i missed from
earlier
um
and it was
sounds like you're running the code
locally were there any specific
roadblocks to offloading that to the
cloud or was that just not really
necessary
so yeah like
all the code ended up going on my
computer for the most part like other
than eli and riker stuff they i think
they managed to get it done but i think
i helped them run a bit of code but
like uh we like my computer was just
strong enough to do what we needed and
it was an overnight process so i had to
just let it run overnight but
the optimal path algorithm and
everything it wasn't too computationally
exhausted where we had to go to the
cloud or anything like that um yeah the
only issue i guess was just
time wise with running all of it but we
basically just stuck to one play at a
time when we were testing things out so
that i don't think that was really a too
much of a problem for us and yeah we
didn't really have to go to the cloud
for anything yeah we were probably on
the borderline of like should we switch
to the cloud and put in all that effort
or should we just send it to brendan and
hopefully it'll run in time
so we probably could have gone either
way
although there's also like you know big
costs going to the cloud especially when
you have like over three gigs of data so
i think that was definitely we didn't
know we were going to win so
that's a good
and then once once the data was cleaned
up like brendan mentioned we were able
to just run like one play at a time
which wasn't too which wasn't too
computationally heavy um but once we got
the data cleaned from the model then
like we would really cut down on the
size of it um and then that was after
that we were kind of good to go
cool and that shiny app that's just on
is that just on shiny apps i o today
yeah yeah awesome
sounds like a great uh shiny submission
for the shiny contest
yeah maybe we'll have to add some
updates and see what we can do
well thank you all so much for for
joining us all here today and
answering all our questions really
appreciate you sharing your experience
with us
thanks for having us
yeah thank you
congratulations
and uh thank you all so much for joining
too
just a reminder um
if you ever have suggestions or want to
present at a future meetup i'll share
those links where you can
upload suggestions or meet up topics in
the recording
and the recording will be the same exact
youtube link that you accessed it at
today
but thank you all again so much for
joining have a great rest of the day
everybody
every